cumplen ya 20 días de que quedaron
atrapados 10 trabajadores de una mina de
carbón en el estado de coahuila al norte
de mexico y a pesar de que suman ya más
de 450 horas de trabajos ininterrumpidos
no ha habido éxito en la localización de
los carboneros las labores de rescate
sean incluso complicado más luego de que
se detectaron nuevas filtraciones de
agua provenientes de una mina abandonada
aledaña a este predio y que se encuentra
inundada es por ello que se encuentran
haciendo nuevos orificios están
barrenando nuevos huecos para detectar
el punto exacto de donde provienen estas
filtraciones y proceder a un sellado con
un cemento especial aislar así las dos
minas secar los pozos y proceder
finalmente al rescate el gobierno
informó que al equipo de expertos se ha
sumado un grupo de geofísicos de la
comisión federal de electricidad para
estudiar las condiciones del terreno
protección civil es federal reiteró que
las empresas de eeuu y alemania que han
colaborado en este rescate han emitido
ya su opinión por escrito en el sentido
de que avalan las acciones emprendidas
hasta el momento por
la exigencia de los familiares no se
sabe que los entreguen a sus seres
queridos aún cuando pudieran estar ya
sin vida el compromiso de las
autoridades es permanecer en contacto
permanente con los familiares y
entregarles el reporte día con día de
las labores de rescate